the one thing they do say which i
noticed because i was listening to a
bunch of podcasts
um on january 6th when the thing
happened at the capitol
and they were in this book they say that
these events are going to start
devaluing
um like basically there's going to be a
massive devaluation
and i remember that thing that happened
on the sixth the storming of the capital
it didn't really reflect itself in the
market the same way
bitcoin kind of stayed the same
everything else kind of stayed the same
stocks were going up i remember a lot of
people that i was listening to and these
were just people who are like you know
speculating constantly and they have
their podcast and they were saying
something is is not right something is
disconnected here from reality
so that is one thing that the book like
it was it was
suspecting that during this period
you're gonna see um devaluation
constantly
maybe it's happening and we're not
seeing it uh oh no no no it is happening
there are reports that the cost of food
is already starting to skyrocket going
up double digit percentages
uh fast food and dining it's just it's
way up
so there's major predictions of food
shortages
and or food inflation so texas had a
food shortage because of the winter
storm it made it impossible for trucks
to come in
but now one of the things one of the
things i'm seeing a lot of people don't
notice this stuff
because we're basically frogs in a pot
we're coming to a slow boil and we don't
realize it
i i saw someone on twitter say i went to
the grocery store to buy a week's worth
of groceries and i couldn't believe it
was almost
double what i normally spend a lot of
people aren't really paying attention to
how much it's costing them
and then there's a couple reasons for it
for one frogs in a pot you don't really
notice these gradual changes
but a lot of people just don't have
money anyway you're we're not getting
the stimulus a lot of people are out of
work they're on unemployment so they're
like i don't know
not paying my rent they're not really
focused on the cost of goods right now
but they are definitely going up
the stock market is a strange disconnect
but maybe it's just because it's a
delayed reaction
yeah it seems like it's 16 months behind
with bitcoin going
up to 50 was it 56 000
for bitcoin before it dipped again
before it dipped again
that says something it went for in only
a few months
it went from 13 000 november to what uh
february 56
000 and only a few months it's
skyrocketed that much
that says something about the confidence
of of the stock market and this country
and i have to wonder if we are just like
you mentioned six to eight months
delayed
before the market takes a hard nose dive
you know you basically convinced me that
it was 2008
because the when the sparks flew of
september 11th it was anxiety
and that if that's a fall that's
anxiety yeah and that's kind of the the
part of the constellation you really
have to look at
our our being and we preemptively strike
you know
we we preemptively went after a nation
or whatever right but they predicted
they predicted that in the crisis or do
they predict that at some point all of
that was during the crisis that i
mentioned so that was a little early
the the the preemptive strike against
another couple
and and you gotta wonder i mean in the
same thing is like you know when you are
exiting
um the real fall going into the real
winter
one starts to look like the other by the
end of fall in the beginning of winter
it does just kind of fade into one
another so this
still could make sense in that respect
but i mean like there's
this was just the inciting incident and
then so like there's a lot of ways of
looking at like what are the sequence of
events
and where does it culminate like where
does it go i think
when it comes to predictions it's very
difficult
depending on your ability to calculate
the variables in front of you you can
make better and better predictions
it sounds like these guys are very very
smart
and they were able to see a wide range
of variables
and track which they thought was the
highest probability based on the things
that were going to happen in their time
period and based on history
in which case they were able to for i
would say fairly
accurately predict things we don't
expect people to be actual psychics who
can tell you on this date at this time
the lottery number will be this
but someone for someone to say there
will be an economic catalyst there will
be
insurrection and militias there will be
fights in the streets and it's like all
that stuff is happening
now the other thing i think people
should understand too is is
semantics and the language they use is
it fair to say when they mention the
militias fighting
would it be fair to say well we've seen
right and left clashes
over the past four or five years in
suburbs and and you know outlying areas
we've seen proud boys in antifa we've
seen right wing groups putting on
shields and helmets and bats and going
and fighting the left
and we've seen the culmination of a
left-wing guy walking up to a right-wing
dude
and just putting two bolts in his chest
is that basically what they're talking
about
my opinion is it's fair to say yes it's
it's definitely fair to say because
again you look at the people
like were there protests in previous
seasons yes
like what does the action look like here
it's it's
you know tensions got a lot higher here
and then i mean you can also go into um
it's kind of interesting because when
you mention that i
i often hear the same trigger words like
why are we hearing the word insurrection
secession um you know obviously the cdc
the spread of a new communicable disease
that blew my mind when i heard that part
of it but then even go into people like
catherine austin fitz and
you could say what you think about her
theories but she was saying
you know when she researched the 37
protests
that happened in 2020 34 of them
happened within a very
short mileage around central well
federal reserve banks
and that a lot of infrastructure was
destroyed around that her theory
um was that it was to basically buy that
infrastructure for pennies on the dollar
build up the smart grid because my big
question is here is like where are we
heading
how can we visualize the spring
what is it going to look like because if
it also changes i mean most people
they're just like war is there going to
be war that's what they're afraid of
but it's also like how is the economy
going to change everything is already
moving towards blockchain it's moving
more digital
a lot more we're a lot more reliant on
the technology
um i think in africa the first baby
was you know unborn child was already
put on the blockchain
and like the moving in this direction
and i've heard the
the the big change the great reset
moving from shareholder capitalism to
stakeholder capitalism
which is you know basically it's just a
restructuring of what our economy is now
and i just find it very interesting it's
definitely going more digital
i think a bitcoin's gonna be worth a
million bucks and it's gonna be worth a
million bucks relatively soon
well uh by relative i mean within a few
years i think one bitcoin be a million
dollars
it's gonna be 75k really fast if you
look at the charts how it shot up to
like 38
back down to 27 up to 56 back down to
45. it's going up to 75
back down to 62. while while you can
look at bitcoin and predict
to a certain degree you can like
actually create you know like here's
what it did here's what it'll likely do
i think the reason we saw this massive
jump
was very different than the previous
what we saw previously with bitcoin was
i just popular uh mentions people
started talking about bitcoin
as they're buying it made the price go
up then more people talk about it
and then it created a snowball rolling
down a hill where everyone's like
bitcoin's so high and everyone's buying
it
i think bitcoin skyrocketed this time
because you have chaos uncertainty
destabilization
capital insurrection donald trump's
claims of fraud all of this stuff
massive inflation
and mass inflation from the previous
year so now you're looking at in you
know
uh insurance companies foreign countries
now now there's rumors that twitter may
buy up a large portion
of bitcoin i think that's proven not
true because they did that apparently to
buy title i guess
but a lot of people are speculating
who's going to be the next big company
to put their balance sheet in bitcoin
because it's a safer bet than dollars
right now
tesla tesla definitely moved the needle
a bit
there's this thing i'm trying to think
of the name it was um
facebook i believe it has it's not a
i don't even think it's a crypto but
it's it's a different kind of
asset that is based upon the average of
all currencies everywhere so it's not
mainly based in one
and that's a protection protectionary
thing where like if
the dollar all of a sudden fails but
everything else stays stable
then you don't feel it that much was
that the libra token the library
that's what it is yeah libra they they
started it and then the sec hit him
pretty hard
he said it was a security so they pulled
back on the program i don't know much
more interesting
yeah i didn't look too much deeper into
that either but i started seeing
in this period a lot of people are
looking forward to the high
and they're wondering like what's stable
and what has endurance what's going to
last like is bitcoin always going to be
the gold standard for crypto
you know i i hear this talk a lot you
know i think so
first in best address i don't see why
not yeah yeah
i guess my my question is how bad will
things get
and uh you know look i have to talk
about fifth generational civil war
information warfare manipulation what do
you think
do you think you think we're in like a
civil war period i've so i've often
thought like
when they said the the weapons of war
will constantly be the most powerful and
effective weapons of war and this time
around
i wonder if it's it's it doesn't seem
like explosions i think you're right it
has to do with
the colonization of the mind um i mean
you could go all the way back to the um
was it the cia director william
casey in the 80s that said like our
disinformation program
will be complete when everything the
american public believes is false
i mean that's a meme i i've found that
also in several books
you know i like there's also william
colby beforehand which was
basically saying yeah we definitely have
you know um
we've infiltrated journalism we have to
because we have to control the narrative
in many ways so the narrative is huge
like if you get people following the
narrative what
was it aldous huxley who said eventually
when when you have people knowing that
they're being oppressed
they revolt but if you can give them
enough bread and circuses
or just bring them their pharmaceutical
revolution
right then how do you get people to be
quite happy
in their servitude so basically
accepting the way things that are going
well
i would imagine you have to control the
narrative so then i start taking a look
at like well what's happening
today social media is so much easier for
everyone in this room is going to have a
different feed
we're going to have something different
showing up on my feed than your feed
and all of that is is part of our
digital twinning
right we all have a digital avatar
potentially run through different
simulations to see
how you know how has been joseph stewart
with all his data going to behave if he
gets these
this kind of media you know it's i think
you know we've heard enough of that even
elon musk saying ai writing blogs and
just like
if something doesn't hit just slightly
adjust slightly just slightly adjust
i think it's information thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you